jó
[Música]
é assim que o meu pai recebe informação
todos os dias há 62 anos sem recurso
nenhum que permita ele adquirir aquela
informação gerar conhecimento e usar
isso no seu dia a dia sem recurso nenhum
de língua de sinais de legenda
isso se chama falta de acessibilidade
contar minha história é contar a
história dos meus pais e meu pai ele se
mudou pra floripa pedindo carona
quando chegou no campeche bairro da
cidade ele morou por um tempo numa
barraca
ele era jovem bonito logo chamou a
atenção das meninas é uma então dia
resolveu sentar do lado dele no ônibus e
ela pensou como é que eu vou me
comunicar
ela pegou um papel pegou uma caneta e
escreveu
qual é o seu nome ele pegou o papel que
pegou a caneta botou a caneta de lado e
pa quebrou ela como uma desculpa para
não precisar dizer que não sabia ler
assim como meu pai 70% dos surdos no
brasil e no mundo
eles não conseguem fazer uma leitura
fluente na língua do seu próprio país
eles não são alfabetizados na língua seu
próprio país muitas vezes porque a
primeira língua deles é a língua de
sinais e sim a língua de sinais ela é
diferente em cada país
aqui no brasil a gente tem a língua
brasileira de sinais
nos estados unidos por exemplo a gente
tem sl américa ensaio língua jô língua
de sinais americana e em cada país a
gente tem uma língua diferente
bom mas essa falta de uma língua de uma
comunicação oficial no início do
relacionamento dos meus pais não foi
empecilho nenhum pra eles hoje têm três
filhos e ter uma vida confortável não
porque foi fácil mas porque eles
enfrentaram muito preconceito eles
passaram por cima disso e porque eles
criaram suas próprias oportunidades
quando eu era mais jovem
eu comecei a perceber que lá em casa a
gente era bilingue vocês se vocês sabem
mas poucas vezes as pessoas preparam um
filho surdo que nasci numa família de
ouvinte
assim como ninguém prepara um filho ou
20 que têm pais surdos e eu demorei para
perceber isso então percebi que lá em
casa a gente tinha é nós darmos bilingue
ea gente se apropriava a gente dividia a
casa com uma pessoa que tinha uma língua
diferente da nossa
uma língua diferente uma cultura
diferente uma cultura super rica
sim a comunidade surda ela tem uma
cultura própria
algumas pessoas não sabem mas a língua
de sinais ela não é só uma soletração de
palavras
ela é uma língua completa como qualquer
outra é uma língua que se usa do espaço
visual é uma língua que se usa de gestos
de sinais mas só gestos sinais não é
suficiente expressões corporais e
faciais podem mudar completamente o
sentido de uma frase bom
logo depois da minha adolescência eu
comecei a fazer faculdade e eu fiz eu me
formei em administração na universidade
federal de santa catarina
logo logo no início do meu curso desde o
início eu sabia que eu não podia sair da
faculdade sem saber inglês sem dominar
essa língua não pôde para o mercado com
isso e foi professor meu me ajudou a
conseguir uma bolsa de estudos no canadá
eu estava totalmente fazer a minha
primeira viagem internacional
chegando lá na primeira semana no canadá
começou a bater um desespero
eu estava num país onde eu não sabia o
básico da língua
eu deitei na cama
não lembro o apartamento estava vazio eu
olhei para o teto e eu comecei a
refletir a resgatar
tudo que eu já tinha visto o meu pai
passar e tudo que já tinha me contado
eu tinha mais cinco meses naquele lugar
como é que eu ia me comunicar com as
pessoas
como é que eu ia fazer amigos como é que
eu ia participar de eventos e palestras
aproveitar toda aquela experiência
então naquele momento no meu quarto eu
pensei se não vai passar por tudo isso e
essa pessoa extremamente alegre
realizado cheia de amigos
o mínimo que eu podia fazer era
aproveitar aquela experiência ao máximo
e foi isso que eu fiz foi incrível
depois eu voltei para o brasil e eu
continuei trabalhando como eu trabalhava
antes com o empreendedorismo eu apoiava
empreendedores eu dava suporte para
negócios e eu via pessoas incríveis
fazerem do seu projecto do seu seu
propósito de vida um trabalho e aquilo
foi crescendo em mim e eu fui que tem
uma vontade muito grande de trabalhar
com educação
e foi aí que eu participei de startup
weekend em 2015
aqui em floripa e foi nesse momento que
eu conheci uma equipe super motivada a
resolver o problema de falta de
acessibilidade dos surdos em alguns
ambientes mas as idéias trabalhar com
surdo não foi minha
foi uma pessoa estava na minha equipe
ela trouxe essa idéia botou isso né pra
galera ea gente escolher a equipe e eu
pensei eu tenho tanta coisa para
contribuir
eu convivo com isso eu nem pensei que
podia usar todas as minhas experiências
no meu conhecimento empreendedorismo
para resolver esse problema
e naquele momento tudo fez muito sentido
pra mim ea gente começou a desenvolver o
trabalho é a gente trabalhou durante um
final de semana que era aquele evento e
durante aquele evento no final a gente
ganhou em primeiro lugar pra mim foi um
empurrão para a vida empreendedora
eu pensei eu tenho a fórmula perfeita eu
posso entender possa empreender na área
de educação que era o que eu queria
posso empreender ajudando a comunidade
surda e eu tenho uma equipe motivada
para isso
e foi naquele final de semana que nasceu
nosso projeto que nasceu a sigma
bom pra mim não foi muito difícil largar
meu emprego dois meses depois estava
realmente motivado e decidida por algum
motivo vários motivos né
e a gente começou então dois meses
estava 100% no projeto a gente começou a
estudar e entender a fundo como é que a
comunidade surda ela buscava o
conhecimento buscava cursos ea gente
descobriu que eles tinham quatro opções
primeira opção pode atrás de livros
certo
na verdade não é que muitos deles não
conseguem ter essa leitura segunda opção
ele pode atrás de um curso presencial
mas os cursos presenciais eles não têm
acessibilidade em libras
não tenho intérprete de libras e às
vezes é o surdo quem tem que pagar por
isso
ou ele tem que fazer leitura labial
já imaginou com é difícil fazer leitura
labial e uma pessoa que usa barba e
bigode uma pessoa que não gesticula
muito a boca ea língua é uma pessoa que
dá aula de costas
realmente é bem difícil bom a outra
opção a terceira opção era buscar trazer
a família os desculpas à família e
amigos é pra ajudar
só que família amiga eles não são
intérpretes e muitas vezes ele tem um
conhecimento muito limitado de libras o
que acontece é que o surdo ele recebe
aquela informação algumas vezes errada
ou pode receber informação também
reduzida para essa falta de prática de
conhecimento de interpretação então isso
também não resolve 100% a quarta opção
que ele tem aí no meio digital buscar
cursos online mas os cursos online
eles não têm interpretação de novo eles
não têm uma legenda
eles estão apenas vendo e olhando uma
pessoa ali falando e mexendo a boca
bom a educação
ela erra erra muito quando ela tenta
ensinar às pessoas da mesma forma sem
perceber que cada um aprende de uma
forma diferente
o surdo quando ele tem acesso à educação
ele tem mais oportunidade para conseguir
uma vaga de emprego e isso impacta na
sua renda familiar
isso impacta também no seu poder de
consumo ea partir daí começa a gerar uma
avalanche de efeitos borboletas na
evolução educacional da comunidade surda
educação é o caminho para a evolução de
qualquer comunidade e por isso que a
nossa missão é levar a capacitação para
surda preparar um surdo para o mercado
de trabalho para as atividades que ele
quer exercer através de cursos online
com a legenda
a maioria dos dados professores nossas
que constroem os cursos eles são surdos
surdos que querem retribuir tudo isso
que a gente faz é levar a oportunidade
para o surdo escolher
é isso que eu quero estudar é isso que
eu quero trabalhar a gente também ajuda
muito
se você já ouviu falar mas existe um
fenômeno na internet existe um efeito
que chama de soundbytes que essa
agregação se a separação entre aquelas
pessoas que têm acesso à internet
aquelas pessoas que não têm acesso à
internet e um surdo mesmo ele tendo
acesso a computador internet não quer
dizer que ele não é afetado pelo digital
de vaidade
ele é assim quando aquele conteúdo ele
não tá acessível para ele
bom depois de dois anos trabalhando com
isso ea gente ajudando nessa diminuição
do impacto digital de vaidade oferecendo
além de cursos dicas também como por
exemplo as dicas de fgts dicas de como
sacar o fgts ensinando o que é um século
que é um cartão de crédito coisa que
muito surdo não tem
nós temos acesso a isso nós conhecemos
isso que a gente tem várias formas eles
não então a sigla faz isso também leva
informação o que eles não poderiam
encontrar nenhum outro lugar
vocês sabiam que tem muito surdo a
grande maioria que não sabe nem o que é
o tex
o primeiro não o primeiro mas um dos
poucos raríssimo sedex no mundo que é
acessível língua de sinais
[Aplausos]
depois de dois anos trabalhando com uma
equipe incrível acertando e errando
muito e aprendendo com a comunidade
surda
a gente hoje está impactando pessoas e
vidas em 24 estados diferentes do brasil
a gente ajuda a realizar sonhos como por
exemplo o sonho da ana que queria ser
professora de língua de sinais americana
mas não podia antes como o sonho do
renato que ele é surdo é paraplégico
também ele não tinha como aprender e
tudo isso só é possível pela equipe
incrível que a gente tem pelos parceiros
e principalmente pela própria comunidade
surda que nos apoia esse meu propósito
de vida ele brotou em mim porque lá
atrás dois seres humanos resolveram
enfrentar as dificuldades que eles
tinham em comunicação e me mostraram que
não é preciso palavras para ensinar é
preciso ter uma comunicação adequada a
quem recebe e foi depois desses dois
anos de trabalho muitos desafios que
hoje eu percebo que eu tô replicando a
história dos meus pais
eu comecei o relacionamento atual uma
pessoa que não fala a minha língua
canadense e eu estou trabalhando com a
comunidade surda essa história dos meus
pais
essa é a minha história é essa história
de 360 milhões de surdos no mundo
essa história de pessoas que estão aqui
hoje e pode estar do seu lado
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]